welcome to the man of recaps this is
westworld season four remember at the
end of season three dolores sacrificed
herself so maeve and caleb could destroy
rehoboam the super ai controlling the
whole world and make a free new planet
for hosts and humans but right off the
bat in season four dolores is back
except she's going by christina and
living in a near future new york she
seems to be living a rom-com lifestyle
where her roommate keeps setting her up
on a series of bad blind dates she works
as a writer on a video game where she's
in charge of the stories of the
background characters but one day this
guy tracks her down like you ruined my
life by writing my story and it ends
with him killing himself so who what
when where why and how christina is
we'll find out later now the main story
begins with caleb seven years after he
and maeve destroyed her hobo um and it's
a nice happy world now he's got a hot
wife and a beautiful daughter frankie
maeve has been living quietly off the
grid but one day some bad guys track her
down and she's gotta go back into murder
mode they're coming after caleb too but
just in time his old friend katana maeve
shows up like hey darling time for
another adventure they discover a lot of
vips have been replaced by robots and
the mastermind is evil dolores
charlottetale yes remember at the end of
season three the car explosion killed
her family and pushed her to the dark
side she doesn't want to coexist with
humans she wants to rule them and to
that end she created a robot william the
man in black but she's actually keeping
the human william alive just so she can
taunt him through him as the owner of
delos she's consolidating power she even
brought back clementine to be his
executive assistant so caleb and maeve
infiltrate the fancy party to find out
what they're up to but turns out they're
on a train headed to
yes another westworld yes they're
opening a new park but we've already
done the cowboy thing this one's set in
prohibition era chicago they did just
reuse all the old westworld loops though
so it's a fun deja vu in a slightly new
setting meanwhile it's time to check in
with bernard remember at the end of
season three he plugged himself into the
sublime the virtual world where all the
old westworld hosts were beamed to here
he meets with one of our old friends
who's like yeah man the sublime is
awesome we've all just made our perfect
paradise worlds but bernard's not here
to stay he's on a mission to save the
world so he uses the sublime to run a
simulation of infinite variations of the
real world and he discovers that it
always ends in mass extinction much like
doctor strange there is one way that he
can save it this took a few years but
now bernard wakes up from his nap and we
find the answer to a huge mystery stubbs
got himself out of the tub and once
again these two best friends are off on
a bro road trip to save the world
bernard has lived all these possible
futures though so he's doing the whole
thing where it's like don't get the
pastrami get the tuna trust me pretty
soon though he hitches a ride from this
cool rebel chick he shows some maze like
yo we're friends she doesn't trust him
but he's like hey i know you're looking
for a super weapon in the desert i know
where to dig over in gangster world
pretty soon maybe and caleb infiltrate
the control center but what's this fake
dolores leading a robot uprising it's
not real though it's part of the game
they programmed in the westworld
massacre so guests can have a thrill
finally they get to the real control
room where they're doing some strange
experiments with flies and they've got
this weird tower that emits creepy tones
below the level of human hearing yes
turns out they're controlling humans and
bad news for caleb they captured his
daughter frankie so he runs in to save
her just in time but that's not frankie
it's a robot copy this was a trap she
opens her mouth and flies fly out i'll
crawl into caleb gross yes this was all
charlotte hale's master plan the flies
infect people with the parasite that
lets her control them with the tower
this new park is just a cover to start
infecting people it's ground zero of a
worldwide mind control outbreak but
maeve still has her superpower to
hackney tech around her so she overloads
the tower blows the thing up and they
capture charlotte hale but as they're
escaping her enforcer the man in black
is here to stop him mabe fights him
while caleb calls the maneuver but now
charlotte hill's like hey caleb aren't
you feeling a little mind controlled yes
she's gonna have him shoot his friend
maeve but caleb fights it oh shoots
william instead it's like what how'd you
break free and he's like i don't know i
just don't like following orders william
doesn't stay down though so to buy time
for caleb to escape babe hugs him real
tight and blows up the explosives but
now caleb's waiting for his ride
charlotte hale's like so do you remember
what happened next wait what yeah it
turns out his men didn't show up
charlotte hale's men showed up and
killed caleb that's right this is not
now it's part of the interview to
establish fidelity this caleb has been
brought back in a robot body and we're
another 20 years in the future where
charlotte hale has won the whole of
humanity under her control it's now
apparent this future is where christina
delores is living and it's also when
bernard woke up this cool rebel chick is
caleb's grown-up daughter frankie and
the super weapon they're searching for
is maeve so the robot uprising is
complete charlottetale has made a
paradise world for the hosts by turning
all of human civilization into reverse
westworld parks it's been fun but she's
kind of bored of it now she's got a new
plan for transcendence where they're
gonna leave behind these human-like
bodies and evolve to their full
potential right now though she's dealing
with a big new problem see they've
always been outliers like caleb who the
mind control doesn't work on they make
it a game where they send hosts to hunt
them down but lately any host who talks
to an outlier goes crazy and kills
themselves so for this latest outlier
her right-hand man robo-williams gonna
take care of it personally but the human
resistance is here too whenever someone
wakes up they go in to try to save them
yes it's just like the matrix but not
virtual the man in black gets to her
first but he hesitates decides to let
her talk and now he's thinking about the
nature of reality so the humans bust in
and save her mission success as for
christina dolores she's on another date
but she drops her lipstick and oh
someone's picking it up it is teddy yeah
he's back but he's not just here for
romance he's here to help wake her up
fills her in that she's not like normal
people and helps her realize she can
control people around her soon she
discovers she's not writing for a video
game she is writing the stories of the
people in the real world so hell brought
back caleb to figure out why mind
control doesn't work on the outliers but
he doesn't know and if he did he
wouldn't tell her she's like hey that's
fine one of you will tell me eventually
yeah she's brought back a bunch of
calebs and remember putting a true human
mind in a robot body doesn't work they
always break down so this latest caleb
has an epic escape attempt where he
finds the other calebs that didn't make
it this far but this one was waiting for
him here like hey man use me to break
your fall so this caleb's made it
farther than ever finds a radio and
reaches out on the frequency to his
daughter i love you baby i'm so proud of
you i know you're gonna win of course
this whole escape was charlotte hale's
plan too to see what he would do if he
escaped and she's like wow you just
radioed your daughter to say i love you
this was a waste of time so hail brings
back one final caleb but she doesn't
care about outliers anymore she's done
with humanity she's gonna shut down all
the parks and do forced transcendence
for all hosts william those not
interested in transcendence he likes his
fleshy body and hanging around messing
with humans especially since he talked
to the outlier he's having a crisis of
who am i so he goes to talk to his human
self hey human me what would you do and
it's like hey i burned this whole thing
to the ground yeah you know what you're
right so he finally kills human william
now frankie and bernard are trying to
bring maeve back online but when her
rebel friends get there she shoots
bernard like yeah man i figured out
you're a robot i can't trust you but
bernard's like hey me and stubs are good
robots but one of your rebel friends has
been replaced by a bad robot and pretty
soon she figures out which one they're
having a fight but then maeve is awake
and takes this guy out it's like well
that's been a good nap darling but time
to save the world again first bernard
takes maeve to the hoover dam which has
been turned into a massive
self-sustaining server room yes this is
where charlotte hale sent the sublime
remember bernard's the only one with the
key to it so he unlocks it they'll need
that later then they head to the tower
for the final showdown between maeve and
charlotte hale let everyone be free no
they don't deserve to be free while
they're fighting bernard sneaks up to
the control room to leave a cryptic
video message this was the only way
meanwhile christina dolores quits her
job which causes enough distraction for
stubbs and frankie to get in there and
rescue robot caleb yes father daughter
reunited but now maven hale's epic fight
is rudely interrupted by the man in
black but he's not here to save hale he
quits his job too and shoots her he goes
to the control room and kills bernard
too then gives the tower its final
command everyone kill each other in a
massive battle royale his philosophies
like this whole world sucks let's just
burn it all down so charlotte hale's
paradise sims game has been replaced by
williams fortnite charlotte's not done
yet though he missed her memory core so
she puts herself in a new metal robot
body and is ready for battle he
destroyed the tower though so she can't
override his last command but she finds
bernard's video message she's like hey i
know you wanted to make a good world but
you made a bad one and it's gonna end
now but there's one hope for the future
it is christina dolores turns out she's
not really here with a body she is just
plugged in to the computer monitoring it
she's now completing her journey of
self-discovery turns out she led herself
down the maze to self-awareness so now
charlotte grabs her pearl flies over to
the hoover dam she's going to put her in
the sublime but william got here first
he's going to delete the sublime to
destroy everything and they have their
final shootout meanwhile back in the
city frankie caleb and stubbs are trying
to escape they're interrupted by
clementine who kills stobs now then
frankie kills clementine too yes
everyone dies in this finale robot caleb
gets his daughter to the escape boat but
it's like i can't come with you baby
because my body's all falling apart i'm
a robot so they have their tearful
farewell but frankie's gonna be okay
back at the dam william's winning but
bernard knew all this would happen and
he planted a gun there for charlottetale
to now grab and take him out so evil
dolores charlotte hale saves the sublime
and puts good dolores in there she
really thought she was doing the right
thing creating a perfect world by
enslaving humanity but now she
understands that didn't work and so she
deletes herself and so what season four
comes to an end life on earth is truly
going extinct but the hope for the
future rests in the sublime where good
dolores is hanging out with teddy and
admits that he's not the real teddy he's
just her imaginary friend but he's like
i don't care baby i love you the real me
is theoretically in here somewhere so
you can meet up and we'll be together
then but dolores who was plugged into
the whole world has memories of all of
humanity and could recreate them
digitally she knows humans can be evil
but they can also be good and it's her
whole thing i choose to see the beauty
in this world so she says it's time for
one more game one final chance for
humanity and hosts to live together and
not destroy each other and she's gonna
run the simulation in digital westworld
yes back to the park the best place to
be i guess to find out who you really
are inside and that's where westworld
season 4 comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]